Okay. Um, good morning. So, this class
we are focusing on William Shakespeare.
But before I do that, I want to give you
an overview of how we will end the
course. Um, to end the course, we will
we will focus on the four great modern
civilizations that have fought for
global dominance these past 20 years.
These four great civilizations are the
Russians, the Germans, the British, and
the Americans. Now what's interesting
about um all four civilizations is that
they all claim to be the the um ultimate
Christian civilizations that are here to
Rome. But because of the differences in
their geography and their culture, they
have different interpretations of
Christianity and Romanness. Okay. So
let's compare and contrast these four
great civilizations. the Russians. Uh as
you know, Russia is the largest land
mass in the world. It is huge. It is
also really cold and dark. Okay. So the
geography
um transform the Russian character.
Okay. Um Germany in contrast it is
within Europe and it does not have the
natural boundaries that the other
nations have. It is always being
attacked and threatened by adversaries.
Okay. Um, the British, it's an island
fortress. The Americans um are the most
interesting because it is a continental
fortress. It is not only invincible. It
cannot be invaded, but also has all the
resources it needs in order to have a
thriving modern economy. Therefore,
America can choose to isolate itself
from the rest of the world. Okay. Now
because of the difference in geography
you have differences in Christianity and
in its Romanness. So the Russians
believe that they are here to the
bisantine empire and as such they are
the protectors of something called
eastern orthodoxy. Okay. So to
understand what eastern orthodoxy is
think of augustine. Okay we read
Augustine city of god. So it is a very
mystical metaphorical
u
collectivist attitude towards religion.
In contrast the Germans believe that
they are here to the Holy Roman Empire
first initiated by Charlemagne and as
such they are more Catholic than the
Russians. Okay. Then you have the
British who believe they are here to the
real Roman Empire. Um and their religion
is angling. Okay, remember Anglicanism
there's really really little difference
between Catholicism and in Anglinism
when in Anglicanism you swear allegiance
to the king of England. In Catholism you
swear allegiance to the pope of the
Vatican.
Um and then you have the Americans who
have a who believe that they are adheres
to the Roman Republic. Okay, not the
empire, the republic before the time of
Julius Caesar, the best former
government in the world. Um the religion
um so the elite is something we call um
das. Okay. So they believe in God but
God as someone who is removed from the
world. You also have many different sex
of panism. Okay. So the religion in
America it is very diffuse very diverse.
Okay. So um different c cultural the
different cultural outlooks will also
determine their cultural identities. So
for example the Russians um they have
the thing that differentiates the
Russians is they have a very dark
imagination. So some of the greatest
literature, some of the greatest music
philosophy actually comes from Russia.
So think of Toy Story, Dossi. In terms
of music, you have Tchaikovski and
Stravinski. Okay, I will also show you
that uh the Russians produced the
greatest geopolitical leaders in
history. So in the 20th century, the
greatest geopolitical leader was
actually Joseph Stalin. And I will show
you I I'll show you this is the case uh
when we move to the 20th century today.
The greatest yopula leader in the world
is Vladimir Putin. So there's something
about the Russian dark imagination that
produces men of genius to lead their
countries. Um the Russian cultural
identity is the idea of mother Russia,
the land itself, the nation, the people.
It is
divine. All right. And so the main
objective of all Russian geopolitical
leaders is to protect its borders from
enemies because because Russia is so
huge and encompasses two continents. Um
it has a lot of geopolitical enemies.
Okay. So that's the Russian um
civilization. When we move to the
Germans, the Germans are really
interesting because the Germans have
also the great human civilizations in
history. Okay. So rather than a dark
imagination, the Germans believe in the
idea of will to power. We will discuss
this when we discuss German philosophy,
especially nichi. Okay. But the idea is
this that we have the capacity to impose
our will on reality. That's the idea of
will to power. We don't we are not
subject to culture. We're not subject to
reality. There are great men among us
who can impose their will on all of us.
Okay? And that's why you have Hitler and
the Nazis. Okay. Um the what the Germans
believe in is the idea of limit. Okay.
Limitum. I know this is a hard word.
It's a German word, but it's actually a
pretty easy concept. The concept is
called living space. So throughout its
history, German, the German people have
always been invaded, attacked by its
adversaries. So to protect itself, it
needs living space. It needs to move out
and colonize its surrounding
territories, Poland, uh, Russia, Austria
and make it more German so that the
German nation can thrive. Okay, very
simple concept. Okay, but this is the
concept that drives the German uh
military strategy in World War I and
World War II. Okay, limits Rome. You
have the British and the British as we
discussed last class, they are a very
practical people. The philosophy is
empiricism and utilitarianism. Okay,
it's not a question of what is right or
what is ideal. It's a question of what
works now. Okay, the British are
extremely practical. Um the British
Empire is based on the concept of white
men's burden. Meaning that the British
culture is inherently superior to all
other cultures and as such the British
have a responsibility to go out and
civilize and educate and enlighten all
others. Okay. So this is the philosophy
that drives the British Empire. The
Americans are interesting because they
are a new civilization and they try to
base their culture on the ideas of the
enlightenment. Okay. So Rouso Kant
especially John Lock um their driving
ideology is the idea of manifest
destiny. So the idea of manifest destiny
is that it is the obvious will of God
for America to control the entire
Western Hemisphere. That's why Trump
today is saying we should take over
Canada. We should take over Greenland
because that's always been
part of the American understanding of
the world. It is God's will that America
will eventually control all the entire
Western Hemisphere. Canada will
eventually come into America into
America as well and eventually America
will drive out all European powers
including Denmark and Britain from the
Western Hemisphere. Okay. So next class
we'll discuss uh America in greater
detail. Today we will focus on the
British Empire which is founded by
William Shakespeare. Okay. So we will
discuss William Shakespeare today. Uh
next week we'll start to focus on the
Russians and the Germans. Okay. These
are the four great
civilizations that will drive history
from from the 19th century up to today.
Okay. And I will also show you later on
that it is actually the
conflict between these four great
civilizations that will drive human
creativity. Science, technology,
um philosophy. Okay. And that's why from
about 1800 up until um 2000 you had a
tremendous flowering of ideas and
culture. Okay. All right. So that's the
game plan for the rest of semester. Any
questions about this
framework? Again, you don't have to know
these ideas right away. I'll explain
them in detail to you as we move
forward. Okay? But understand the
overall framework is there are four
different civilizations that will drive
human uh modernity and they are in
conflict with with each other and it's
because of this conflict that drives
human
innovation. All
right. Okay. Let's move on. So the
shakes the question we're looking at
today is how did Shakespeare transform
English into the language of empire? So
for the longest time, English is what
they what they spoke on the British
Isles. Okay, not even the British Isles,
primarily in England. So how did
Shakespeare transform that into the
language that everyone speaks today?
Okay, English really is the language of
empire. You think when you learn
English, you're not just learning uh
grammar and vocabulary. You are really
learning a culture, a philosophy, an
identity. All right? Right. And what's
amazing about English is that it has
really created
um it it's really for soft power
convince everyone to believe that
Anglo-American culture is really the
best in the world when objectively
speaking it is not. I you can make the
argument that Russian and German culture
is far superior to Anglo-American
culture. But everyone especially young
people in the world today believes that
Anglo-American culture is just vastly
superior. And the reason why is because
most people speak English and we absorb
um um our understanding of the world
through language. Okay? Right? So that's
the question we're looking at today. All
right? So before we talk about
Shakespeare, I want you to understand
some basic principles about language,
art, culture and civilization. Okay. The
first major principle is great art.
Okay. Dante, Homer, uh, Vamir,
Shakespeare. It lifts the soul of
civilization and changes the
neurological neurological structure of
societies creating a new way of being
and seeing.
Okay. So this is a really important idea
where you have to understand that
civilization has a collective
consciousness. And what great art does
is it seeps into this collective
consciousness and rewires the brain to
make the civilization see the world in a
new way which causes people to behave
differently. Okay. So we discussed this
about Homer and Dante, right? Especially
Homer and Dante. Today I'll show you how
Shakespeare radically transformed the
English
imagination. All right. Another idea I
need I need I need you to understand
is how poets transform civilization is
they innovate in imagery, grammar and
vocabulary. Okay. And when they do that
poets expand a civilization's capacity
to imagine, feel and
think. Okay. So
um we will discuss William Shakespeare.
William Shakespeare did not live very
long. He died at 52. Okay. So he was not
alive for a very long time. But his
accomplishments are amazing. In his
brief life he wrote anywhere between 38
to 41 plays and he established the
English culture identity. Okay.
Shakespeare is really the founder of
English culture and he established the
his English historical memory. Okay? And
he did this by writing a lot of plays,
right? So tragedies, histories,
comedies, you've read some of them in in
in um in in school, right? So his
accomplishments are tremendous. The
reason why we don't know how many plays
he actually wrote, okay, is he never
published in his lifetime. All his plays
were published after his death by his
friends who are working with his notes
as well as as um recollections from
actors who participated in Shakespeare's
plays. That's why so we don't have
actually anything written specifically
by Shakespeare. Okay, so keep that in
mind. Um in his plays he used anywhere
between 20,000 to 30,000 different
words. So his range of vocabulary was
just vast. What's really unique about
Shakespeare is he introduced anywhere
between 1700 to 3,500 new uses of words.
What we call diction. Okay, I I'll show
you what diction is later on. To put
this in context, between the years 1500
and 1650, around 10,000 new words are
being introduced into into England
because of re revolutions in
agriculture, in trade, um in
communication, in technology. Okay. So,
at this point in history, England is um
going out into the world and it's
transforming it society and therefore it
needs to bring in new words. What
Shakespeare does that's really important
is he
transforms the British
imagination in order to better um absorb
these new ideas and he does so through
new new uses of words what we call
diction. Okay so this makes sense guys.
Okay so let's let's examine how he does
this. Let's let me give you an example.
Let's look at the word dagger. Okay.
Dagger means just a short sword. Okay.
And it's a very common English word. But
what Shakespeare does is he uses it in a
really imaginative metaphorical way that
forces you to reimagine the world around
you. Okay? So let's look at some
examples. And these are my examples by
by the way. They're not Shakespeare's
examples. All right? We will look at
Shakespeare examples later on. All
right. So the first example is he has a
dagger fat and short. Okay. This is
interesting because when we see a
dagger, we think of something that is
um thin, right? This is saying this is
fat. All right? So, this forces you to
to think about what dagger is as a
metaphor. And this makes your mind
think, oh, here's a dagger fat and
short. So, it's possible that on the
surface he looks fat and short, but
actually as a person he is lean and
mean. He's very very clever. He's
pretends he's stupid, but he has he has
very precise
um cleverness. Okay. All right. So
that's what Shakespeare does. He takes a
traditional metaphor and he radically
reverses or inverts it to force you to
reimagine things in a new way. All
right. That's the first example. Second
example is I daggered him with
questions. Now the word daggered
actually exists in English language but
it means you carry a dagger with you.
Okay? So if I say I am daggered it means
my there's a dag my pocket and that's a
traditional use of dagger. But there's
no reason why you can't do what
Shakespeare does and says I daggered him
with questions which means like I stab
him with questions. All right I'm
threatening him with questions. I ask a
lot of questions and this is very
visual. It's very imaginative. Okay. Now
the third example is his voice is
daggerly. Dagly as a word does not
exist. But because you know what the
word dagger means you can imagine what
dagly could mean right? A voice that is
like mine very high high high. Okay. And
which you feel um is jabbing at you. All
right. So that's the genius of
Shakespeare. He takes words that we use
every day and he finds new ways of using
it in his plays that forces us to
reimagine the world in a different way.
All right, that's the power of
Shakespeare. Now, um what this is saying
is this what Shakespeare understands is
that language can be a portal into the
neur neurological framework of our
minds. Right? So you might have some
study some neuroscience or psychology
you know like our brain it's structured
by these things called synapses okay
these pathways in our brain and what
Shakespeare understands is that by
manipulating language in a new way you
can also perform a sort of surgery on
the synapses. All
right. All right. So Shakespeare as
music. The thing to remember about about
Shakespeare is his plays were meant to
perform as musicals. Okay. Um today in
school we have you read Shakespeare but
remember during the time of Shakespeare
no one read him. You experienced
Shakespeare by going to his plays and
his plays were musicals.
uh when people spoke Shakespeare it was
as though they were singing and also
there were lots of like dance routines
within the place as well remember these
are people who are extremely ordinary
okay who are going to Shakespeare as a
form of mass entertainment it's almost
like the equivalent of like going to
movies today and the way that
Shakespeare creates music in his place
is through a device called pentameter
okay pentameter um you know right it's
Um, amus is just uh the arrangement of
syllables where you have one one that is
deep and then another that's high. So
deep, high, deep, high, deep, high,
deep, high, deep, high. When you have 10
syllables, it's called pentameter. Okay.
So an example of course is to be or not
to be or that is the so so you you
understand how this works right low high
low high low high and Shakespeare does
that throughout his plays that's why it
comes across as musical but if it's
musical then then it's easy to remember
because it becomes like a song right
it's really easy for us to remember
songs
So e andic pentameter Shakespeare's
plays are memorable, beautiful and
resident meaning they touch our
souls and again these are people. So
through I'm a pentameter Shakespeare is
performing a surgery on the imagination
of civilization right all right so
having said that let's go into some
brief history about Shakespeare um
during the time of
Shakespeare theater is extremely popular
around the
country and theater is primarily the
means of mass entertainment but it's
also the means of mass education if you
want to know about history. If you
aren't about culture, um you go to the
theater. Now, problem with this is that
during the time of Shakespeare around
the 16th century, as we discussed last
class, there's a major conflict going on
between the Protestant religion and the
Catholic religion. And so the the queen
Elizabeth is concerned about theater as
a means of creating the scent in
society. So what they do is they force
all the theater productions to be placed
in a suburb of London. Okay, that's
where Shakespeare is going to work. By
doing that um Shakespeare is being
introduced to all the major theater of
that time. Okay, so Shakespeare never
actually wrote anything that is unique.
Okay, so Hamlet, Julius Caesar, Ollo,
King Lear, these are all plays that are
um part of the British theatrical
imagination. But what he does that's
different is he reimagines the
characters and introduces new diction
into the plays to make it beautiful.
Right? So this is the globe which is
where Shakespeare performed much of his
productions. Right? The globe
theater. Um the thing also remember
about this time is theater is low class.
All right. So a in this district the
this district there are lots of brothel.
People go to theater and they get drunk.
Okay, they're drinking, they're
spitting, they're eating stuff. They're
also part participate in something
called in a gambling activity called
bear baiting. Okay, bear baiting is
really strange, but the idea is you take
a bear, you chain him up, you blind him,
okay? And then you have dogs attack him,
and then you bet who wins, the bear or
the dogs? And this is a really popular
thing to do at this time, right? So it
just shows you that we think of
Shakespeare as very high class and we
teach Shakespeare as high class but at
this time Shakespeare is very very low
class and Shakespeare's plays are
performed uh right beside beer baiting
uh venues as well as brothel right but
this is important
because because if Shakespeare is
reaching to the
masses right he's educating the masses
into a global imagination
All right. Um Shakespeare and theater
it's so detested by the upper class that
from 1642 to 1660 the Puritans banned
from England. Okay, remember we
discussed the Puritans and how they're
obsessed with uh control. They hate
alcohol. They hate fun. They hate
theater especially theater. They hate
Shakespeare. Okay, so they banned it. So
during this time Shakespeare is
extremely controversial.
Um so having gone into history let's
discuss the genius of Shakespeare. Okay.
Um you you do Shakespeare in school.
You've read quite a few of his plays. So
I'm not going to go too deeply but I'm
going to focus on one example that
distinguishes um Shakespeare from all
other playrs. Okay. So the example I
want to use is Hamlet. Okay. Hamlet. The
story you know it's a very simple story.
It's about this prince of Denmark called
Hamlet. He's going to university in um
um Germany um I believe Wikenstein which
is where Martin Luther went. He comes
home and then he's visited by the ghost
of his dead father. And the ghost of his
dead father tells Hamlet, I was killed
by your uncle Claudius who now has
stolen the throne from me as well as
married my wife Gertrude your mother. It
is your responsibility as my son to seek
vengeance against Claudius. Okay. So
that's the mission of Hamlet. The
problem is that Hamlet, he is a very
analytical person. He thinks too much.
Paralysis is analysis. Okay? So he
spends the entire play thinking about
how to kill him, kill Claudius, but also
whether or not to kill Claudius. And
this is why we believe that Hamlet is
Shakespeare's best play because it is a
very deep philosophical work. And in
many ways, Hamlet is really the
expression of Shakespeare. Um, you may
not know this, but Shakespeare had a son
called Hamnet. And Hamlet actually died
when he was young. So, a lot of um
scholars of Shakespeare, and there are
like thousands of scholars on
Shakespeare believe Hamlet is
Shakespeare's most personal play. All
right. So we're going to go into a bit
of Shakespeare and look at the most
famous siloquy in Shakespeare to
understand how he thinks how he writes.
All right.
So this again this is amic pentameter to
be or not to be that is the question.
Whether it is nobler in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or to take arms
against a sea of troubles and by
opposing end them to die to sleep no
more and by asleep to say we end the
heartache and a thousand natural
shocks that flesh is here to a
consummation devotely to be wished to
die to sleep to sleep her chance to
dream. I there's the rub for in that
sleep of death. What dreams may come
when we have shuffled off this mortal
coil must give us pause. There's respect
that makes calamity of soul long life.
Thus conscious dove make cowards of us
all and thus the native hue of
resolution is slick over with a pale c
of thought and in a pris of great pith
and moment with this regard the currents
turn arry and loosen of action. Okay, so
some brief comments about the
slickquake. First of all, as you can
understand, it's beautiful, right? It's
also, if you think about it, pretty easy
to read. There are lots of really
complicated words in the speech, but
it's really smooth, right? If you read
it for yourself, it's really smooth. And
that's the power of pentameter. If you
really want to be fluent in English,
just read Shakespeare aloud for a few
months and your English will be perfect.
Okay. Um, the British really are the
best practitioners of English. If you
read magazines like The Economist
um, it's really the best written
magazine in the world. And you think to
yourself, well, duh. The British
invented English, right? Uh, no. Okay.
Just because you invent something
doesn't mean you're good at it. So, the
Chinese invented gunpowder, compass,
printing, paper. Didn't really get us
anywhere. Okay. The fact of the matter
is that in England, you're expected to
read and know
Shakespeare, right? So, it's Shakespeare
that allows the British to have amazing
English. All right? So, this is very
complicated, but it's actually not
that deep. Okay? It's not like Dante.
Dante is very, very deep, but
Shakespeare is actually not that deep.
All right? So, let's look at what it
actually means with these words. Okay?
To be or not to be, that is the
question. Against the misfortune in our
lives, is it more brave and good to bear
it or to stand against it? I no longer
want to bear this pain. Let me sleep. I
no longer want to feel my heartache and
my body become weak and injured. That is
my wish. I want to sleep and to dream.
But that is a danger, isn't it? When we
are dead, we cannot control what we
dream. And that is what frightens me.
And that's why I continue to build more
misfortunes around me. It is my own mind
that has made me a coward and why each
time when I become determined my resolve
breaks apart and I cannot act. Okay,
that's what he's saying. That's like
literally what he's saying. No
difference. But of course when you do
this when you simplify Shakespeare you
lose the beauty and richness of
Shakespeare. All right. So now question
then is why is Shakespeare so
complicated? What's he trying to do with
his language? Okay. So the first thing
that he's trying to do is he's trying to
use language as a mechanism to convey
different realities, different meanings.
Okay? So within Shakespeare with each
with each of his plays, there are many
different layers of meaning that can be
true at the same time. All right? So let
me show you an example of this. Let's
look at the first possible
interpretation of to be or not to be.
Okay? You can say it means to die or to
live. I cannot decide. I do not know if
it's more brave to live a painful life
or to run away from it and escape into
death. So this is saying that Hamlet is
overwhelmed by the moral dilemma he's
put in. Okay, he cannot u escape. He he
has to avenge his father, right? Or he
cannot sleep. But avenging his father
means killing his uncle who his mother
loves. Okay, it's an impossible moral
dilemma. He doesn't he doesn't want to
deal with it. So he wants to kill
himself. Okay, that's one possible
interpretation. Another possible
interpretation is to kill or not to
kill, I do not know. Is it more good to
let those who do evil suffer their own
fate or should I stop their evil and end
their lives? Okay, so you can interpret
this as saying he's asking himself, how
should he kill Claudius? Should he kill
Claudius? Okay, that's a different
interpretation. Yet another
interpretation is should I follow my
fate or should I defy it? Is it more
brave and good to do as I am told or to
fight against my fate? and in so doing
perhaps die. Okay, so this is a much
more deeper and richer meaning where
he's talking about fate and life in
general. He's making the argument that
we are we have no free free will. We are
forced into a situation where we must do
what fate tells us. And in this
situation, what does it mean to be
human? What does it mean to have free
will? Where you're controlled by the
forces of fate around you. Okay, so
that's a much deeper meaning. And then
the last deep meaning is what is the
point of existence? I do not know. When
we exist, we must face pointless
questions in our lives. Should we suffer
or should we fight? Okay, so this is the
deepest meaning where he's ask he's he's
actually asking what does what is
existence? What is the point of all
this? How do we get
here? What is the purpose of existence?
Okay, so there are four possible
interpretations of this speech and
they're all correct. you can interpret
them any way they want. Okay, so it's
the first power of Shakespeare where
he's forcing you to interpret his speech
in different ways. Okay, the second
power of Shakespeare is it's visual.
Okay, in this tradition, in this oral
culture where no one reads and writes,
well, most people don't read and write,
uh, most people are accessing
information
through words, right? And in this
tradition, words are images. All right.
So let's go over the silicquay and see
how they are images. Okay. So when
Hamlet says suffer the slings and arrows
of outrageous fortune or take arms
against a sea of troubles and by posing
in them, the audience is seeing these
pictures. They're seeing a movie in
their heads. Okay? That's the attraction
of
Shakespeare. Okay? Do you guys see this?
Is it clear to you guys? All right. And
because you're seeing pictures, they
remember all this. Okay, if you when you
talk to an English person, it's amazing
how much Shakespeare that person knows
subconsciously. Another image. Okay. In
that sleep of death, what James may
come, we have shoveled off this mortal
coil must give us pause. All right. So,
this is an image of a person who's dead.
So, his soul goes up to heaven. But
what's in heaven? What's that sleep of
death? No one
knows.
Okay, another image. The native hue of
resolution is slick over with a pale
pass of thought. Okay, so this is a
complicated sentence, but it's really
about how something that is clear to us
once we think about it becomes very dark
and
unclear. Right? So that's a power of
Shakespeare. It's a visual language.
All right, another example. Enterprise
of great pivot moment. Their currents
turn to rise and loss of action. Right?
So imagine a ship. It's going very it's
going in a direction. You're set on that
path. But the moment you think about it,
the think the moment you think deeply
about what you're doing, um the ship
collapses. You don't know where you're
going
anymore. Right? So is that clear to you
guys?
All right. So, another example of the
power of Shakespeare is uh Julius
Caesar. I'm not sure if you read Julius
Caesar in uh school, but Julius Caesar,
it's a very I mean, the plot is very
simple. Um Julius Caesar, he has
defeated all his enemies in the Roman
Civil War. And his friends, Brutus,
Casius, um they're worried that he'll
become a dictator. They're they're
worried that he he'll become king. So,
they plot to kill him. and Brutus and
Casius and all the conspirators kill um
Julius Caesar and then Brutus and Cas
think this is over. Okay. But Mark
Anthony who is Caesar's lieutenant, he
swears vengeance and Mark Anthony and
Octavian will combine forces to destroy
and kill Brutus and Cases. And that's
the plot of Julius Caesar. Not very
complicated, okay? But in Julius Caesar
you will find some of the greatest
speeches in the English
language. It's stunning speeches. Okay.
And in the speeches you will find
example of how Shakespeare understands
language as a surgery on the brain. How
through speech making, how through
language you can actually transform the
neur neurological structure of the human
brain. Okay. So let's look at an example
of this. Mark Anthony and Brutus are
going to engage in a speech competition.
They're going to debate each other.
Okay? Brutus will be the first to give a
speech and then he'll be followed by
Mark Anthony. So the strategy of Brutus
is is you use a rhetorical strategy
called the antithesis. Okay? The
antithesis is basically very simple. You
have two opposing ideas. Okay? And there
are opposed to each other. So the idea
is I am Buddhist. I am honorable. You
know me as honorable because my name is
Brhus which is also the name of Lucius
Brhus who founded the Roman Republic.
You know me as honorable person. Now who
is Caesar? Caesar is
ambitious. Okay, honor and ambition
cannot go
together. So I love Caesar but because
he was ambitious he wanted to enslave
us. I want to free us. Therefore I have
to kill him. All right. So that's the
idea of Buddhist. He's trying to create
a economy between Caesar and himself. If
you know me Brutus as honorable, then
you must believe that Caesar is
ambitious. This rhetorical strategy is
what we call the antithesis. Okay, in
the human mind, you just see these two
things as separate from each other. Mark
Anthony then responds to Brutus using
something called the triasmus. Okay, the
triasmus, it's really interesting. The
triasmus take tries to take these two
opposing principles and combine them
together. All right. So what Mark
Anthony will say is that Caesar was
ambitious and honorable as honorable and
ambitious as Buddhist. This is called we
call triasma. It's called it's an a bba
structure. When you do that when you
have a triasmus you collapse the
antithesis. Remember the antithesis are
two separate ideas that cannot meet
together exclusionary. The chasma shows
you like these are mirrors of each
other.
Okay. When you do that in the in the
Roman imagination, human Roman mind, you
then collapse the economy between Brutus
and Caesar and you see them as one and
the same. But if it was Brutus that
killed Caesar, then Brutus must be the
less honorable and ambit and more
ambitious one. Okay? Does that make
sense, guys? Julius Caesar. All right?
So, let's see an example of this. All
right? This is Brutus si talking to the
Roman crowd after the death of Julius
Caesar. Okay, he's trying to explain his
actions before the Roman crowd. He says,
"If then that friend demand why Brutus
rose against Caesar, this is my answer."
Okay, you want to know why he killed
Caesar? I'm going to tell you why he
killed Caesar. Not that I love Caesar
less, but I love Rome more. Had you
rather Caesar were living and die all
slaves than that Caesar were dead to
live all free men? This is an
antithesis, right?
I love Caesar but I love Rome more.
Okay, this is antithesis. This is also
antithesis. Caesar if you were living he
we he would make us into slaves. If
Caesar is dead we will continue to live
as free men. Okay, two exclusionary
ideas developed by Brutus. Now what Mark
Anthony is going to do is he's going to
collapse this. Okay, he's going to
change your neurological structure. He's
going to change your synapses within you
through his speech making. Let's look at
Mark Anthony. Yet Buddhist says he was
ambitious and sure he is an honorable
man. Okay, so he's summarizing uh the
argument made by Buddhist. I speak not
to disprove what Buddha Buddhist spoke,
but here I am to speak what I do know.
You all did love him once, not without
cause. What cause withholds you than to
mourn for him? Okay, this is a tasmus
cause love mourn. Okay, you guys see
that? He continues with a
tasmus. But yesterday the word of Caesar
might have stood against the world. Now
lies he there and none so poor to do him
reverence. Oh masters, if I were
disposed to stir your hearts and minds
to mutiny and rage, I should do Brutus
wrong and Cass's wrong, who you all know
are honorable men, I will not do them
wrong. I rather choose to wrong the dead
to wrong myself and you than I will
wrong such honorable man. Okay, this is
two examples of tismas where word of
Caesar and reverence match stood and
lies match. Okay, for the chasm he's
collapsing this economy. Another example
is here. Okay, the red match the green
match. This this is what we call
chasmus. Does that make sense
guys? Okay. Have you guys learned this
before? Okay. It's really important. You
know, you know these ideas. All right.
So, that's the power of Shakespeare.
Through his language, through his
rhetoric, he's transforming the British
imagination so that they are more open,
more fluid. They can absorb new ideas
and they can be more innovative. Okay.
Now we we as we discussed way back at
the beginning of this course, Homer did
the same thing. So let's compare and
contrast Homer and Shakespeare. How was
it able that they were both able to be
founders of great civilizations? All
right. First of all, they came at a time
when there's a cultural tabular
rasa. Okay, tabular rasa just means
blank slate. So Homer came at a time
after the branch age collapse of Greece.
The misanian civilization collapsed and
now you have this the polar system.
Okay. So it's a tabala rasa. Same thing
with Shakespeare where Britain at this
time it is not an advanced culture as
much as the French and um the Spanish.
Second is rapid cultural change where
Britain is undergoing all these
revolutions. when you when it's
undergoing all these revolutions, people
are anxious and they're looking for new
ideas. Oral culture, okay, we we talked
about this where if you live in an oral
culture, people have a stronger memory
and have a greater imagination. That's
why they're able to sit through three
hours of Shakespeare at one go at at one
um one go and visualize his language.
And this is like the most common person
in Britain. Okay, these are not the
elite. These are just commoners. And so,
um, we have an oral culture, you have a
stronger memory, imagery, vibrancy, and
flexibility. They look guys, I I hate to
say this, but back then they were
smarter than we are today. We have, you
know, Google and chatbt, but if you
think about it, all these things are
just making us stupid.
Okay. Um, open cooperative competition
just means that in their times, Homer
was just one of thousands of bars that
are traveling around uh, Greece and
singing legends of the Trojan War and
the Golden Fleece. Okay, so what they
were doing was they were stealing from
each other. All right, Shakespeare was
stealing from everyone else. And that
allows for rapid innovation when when
you have an open cooperative
competition. Democratic sensibilities.
This is really important. Okay. Homer
was talking to ordinary people.
Shakespeare was talking to ordinary
people. The problem with today's culture
is um there's a lot of uh market
differentiation where if you feel that
you are high class, you're university
professor. You don't want to talk to
common people. You want to talk to other
university professors. That leads to
stagnation and segmentation. Okay. Uh
free market really important idea where
how do you know if you look good or not?
Okay. Well, in a university, you know if
you're good or not if a professor tells
you you're good or not. But how do you
know the professor knows what he's
talking about? The free market provides
an objective feedback loop- which forces
you to constantly innovate and improve,
right? How do you know you're good?
Because people come and listen to you.
They pay attention to your plays. They
want to pay for your place, right? And
it turned out that because of the free
market and open corporate competition,
Shakespeare proved to be the best. Okay.
And the last idea is poet as profit.
Okay. This is a really important idea
where okay, yes, Shakespeare became very
wealthy because of the plays he was
producing. He was he came from a very
common background. He was not very
wealthy. He didn't go to university.
That's why that's why today there are
scholars who believe Shakespeare did not
write Shakespeare because he didn't go
to Oxford or Cambridge. Christopher Maro
wrote to went to Oxford or Cambridge but
not Shakespeare. Okay, so you have a lot
of scholars who actually believe because
he's not well educated. He um could not
have written the place he wrote. But
what drove Shakespeare and what drove
Homer is the idea that you have a divine
mission to spread the truth. Okay. So
Shakespeare and Homer, they were rich,
they were popular, they were famous, but
they were not driven by money. They were
driven by a divine messianic mission to
transform the
world. Okay, does that make sense, guys?
This is really important to understand.
Great artists are driven by
um a messic mission to change the world
for the better. They're not driven by
money or power or fame. All right. So
having done that, let's recap and
summarize the three great poets that
have impacted western civilization.
Okay? And compare and contrast the
three. All right? You have Homer who
founded the Greek civilization. You have
Dante who we discussed in great detail
this semester. He's the founder of
modernity. And you have Shakespeare who
was the founder of the British Empire.
All right. So
um again, Homer, Dante and Shakespeare
were all democrats in their heart.
Homer was a roing bard who went around
the different polices to uh sing and
entertain the masses. Dante was
revolutionary because he wrote divine
comedy not in Latin which was the
language of the educated elite but in
the vernacular in Tuscin so that
ordinary people could access it and by
doing so he transformed tas tuskcin into
the official Italian language that is
spoken
today. Uh Shakespeare again was a
playwright he wrote to entertain the
masses. That's why in Shakespeare you
have such I mean it's it's it's very
offensive someone's language. Okay. All
right. Um they have different
conceptions of language though. All
right. And this is very key for us to
remember. For Homer language is a window
into the human soul. So go back to the
Iliad in the Odyssey. It was really
about what drove us humans. Achilles was
driven by the thirst for fame. Uh
Odysius was driven by his love of Peny
and his son Tamakus. Okay. So uh both
the Iliad and the Odyssey were
tremendous psych psychological studies
of what it means to be human. You have
Dante. Okay. Dante uses language as a
portal into the mind of God. What is the
universe? How did God create the
universe? What does God want from us?
Okay, that's divine comedy. Shakespeare
is very different. Okay, Shakespeare
creates a new idea of language as a
reality onto
itself. All right, a reality onto
itself. So what I mean by that is with
Shakespeare, it's not really a deep
meaning. It's very hard to find deep
truths in Shakespeare. But the language
is beautiful. And this is the culture we
live in today where you know what people
write novels, they use beautiful
language, beautiful description, great
imagery, but there's really not great
truths, deep truths, grand truths in the
novels that are written and produced
today. Okay, so let me give you example
of what it means to have language as
reality onto itself. All right, so let
let me show you show show you what this
means. And to do so, I'm I'm going to
use a different um poet. His name is
John Keats. Okay, John Keats. And this
is from his most famous poem to Autumn,
which is considered the greatest English
poem of all time. All right. So, let's
read it together and then I'll show you
how this is a reality onto
itself. Where are the songs of spring? I
Where are they? Think not of them. Thou
has thy music to you. While barred
clouds bloom the soft dying day, and
touch the stubble plains with rosy hue.
Then in a wealth of choir, the small
nuts mourn among the river shallows born
alive or sinking as wind lives or dies.
And foreground lambs loud bleed from
hilly born. Had crickets sing. And now
with treble soft the red breast whistles
my garden cough and gathering swallows
Twitter in the skies. Okay. So it's
beautiful. What does it mean? All
right. I'm going to show you what it
means. Okay. This is this is language as
real reality onto itself. It is language
visualizing a new world. All right. So
you see how the words match, right?
While barred clouds bloom the soft dying
day and touch the stubble plains with
rosy hue. It's a painting, guys. All
right, this one sentence. It's a
painting of a new world that you can see
in your
heart. Also then in a wealthful choir
the small gnats mourn among the very
shallows born aloft or sinking as our l
as a light wind lives or dies. Okay, you
can see the music within this
picture,
right? This is a not just a picture but
it's a world that you can access because
it's moving. It's alive. It's the power
of
language. Next sentence.
and full grown lambs loud beat from
hilly born head sing and now with treble
soft the red breast whis from a garden
cough okay so you see what's happening
where this poetry it is entering your
soul and is it is activating all your
emotions all your senses there's the
visual okay there's a sound there's a
smell there's a
touch and gathering swallows Twitter in
the
sky. Okay, that's what poetry is. Poetry
is the expression of a new world that
you can
access, right? And when you access it,
when you enter it, it transforms your
soul and your imagination, your capacity
to think, feel, and imagine. Okay. Does
that make sense you
guys? All
right. All right. So, let's summarize
what we learned. Okay. Shakespeare turns
English into the world's linguistic
internet, a platform in which all
cultures, ideas, and worldviews can meet
and
crossbreed. Okay. So Shakespeare is
transforming English into this extremely
flexible,
beautiful, memorable language which
allows everyone to learn English. Well,
you want to learn English well just read
Shakespeare. Okay, that's all you have
to do and then you can master English.
So it's a linguistic
internet. For the first time, all
cultures are able to meet together in
within a English language and
communicate with each other. Okay,
there's a problem with this. There's a
problem with this. The problem is
this. But this exchange is mediated
through Anglo-American civilization
which is at its heart utarian,
skeptical, and
empirical. All right. So when you
embrace English, when you experience
English, you're also
experiencing British culture, history,
and philosophy. Okay? And as we
discussed the three main philosophies of
British culture are utitarian, skeptical
and empirical. Utarian we discussed last
class. It just means that um we should
do things that works as opposed to what
is right. Skeptical is to be skeptical
of our
capacity to reason and to think. If you
think you know something, you probably
don't know it. Okay. And then empirical
just means the only thing you know is
things you
experience. All
right? So in other words, Anglo-American
culture, even though it dominates the
world, it's it's pretty lackluster. It's
very narrow-minded. It's very practical.
It's pretty
mediocre. Okay? And if you want to know
what I mean by that, think about think
think to yourself what when was what was
the last great American novel you read?
I mean there are lots of great Russian
German novels right so Russ Russians you
have Anakarina war in peace um K
punishment the Germans have great
philosophy Kant nichi Hegel we we'll go
into that uh later on okay but I I
struggle to think about what great art
the Americans produce have produced even
though they are the most wealthy most
powerful country that has ever existed
in human history. Okay. And I mean
Shakespeare is great. I mean like like
like I love Shakespeare. King Leair is
one of the greatest plays ever written.
But Shakespeare compared with Dante I
mean I don't know. Okay. Dante is like
you are in the mind of God. You can feel
this is divine. Okay. But with
Shakespeare you're like this is
beautiful
but is it a pretty nothingness?
Okay, that's a question I I have. And
again, to be fair, it's been a long time
since I actually rich read Shakespeare.
I've read most of his plays. Uh, but
it's been a long time since I've read
Shakespeare. So, what I want to do later
on, uh, may maybe a few years from now
is actually teach Shakespeare and see if
I'm wrong. Okay. But, um, right now I I
I have to say Shakespeare is not as
impressive as Homer and Dante, right?
And I think Homer and Dante are the two
greatest poets who ever lived. All
right. So let me give an example of what
I mean by how British culture is kind of
narrow-minded. All right. So this is
considered the greatest epic in the
English tradition called Paradise Lost
by John Milton. And it's really about
um Adam and Eve, right? Why did Adam and
Eve eat that forbidden fruit? and why
were we banished from uh the garden of
Eden? And look um it's 12 books which is
a model of the great epics of integrity
um Homer and uh Virgil and there are
some parts
of Paradise Lodge which are beautiful.
Okay, I mean I love Paradise Lost. I
I've taught Paradise Lost before but the
reality is this as an epic as a grand
vision of the world. It doesn't really
work. Okay. I mean like um I don't
really think the plot the vision of
Paradise Lost it is as fully formed and
as grand as Homer and as Virgil and as
Dante. Okay. and and so Paradise Lost,
you might have a chance to read it um in
college one day, but it's a very limited
and narrow-minded uh epic. All right.
So, so let's
conclude. All right. So, we we did
Britain today. Okay. And I hope you
understand
uh British culture. It's an island
fortress. It sees itself as here to
Roman Empire. It is an Anglican
religion. It's driven by the emper
empiricist and utteran philosophies.
Okay. And Shakespeare is really the
founder of this great civilization. Next
class we'll do
America. Okay. And then after we do
these two uh cultures that now dominate
the world, we'll move on to the Germans
and the Russians. Okay? That's the game
plan. But was today's class clear to
you? Do you understand Shakespeare
now? Does this make sense? Okay, any
questions? Anything you're not clear
about? Any questions?
So that's like
Okay. Yeah. So, okay. So, the question
is what is
like like so Shakespeare is played is is
performed all the time and you are
forced to read Shakespeare in school.
So, where is where do we get these plays
from? Okay. So, um let me explain to you
what's happening. All
right. Okay. So, Shakespeare's plays.
All right. So when Shakespeare was
alive,
um he didn't really publish his
plays. Okay, he didn't publish his
plays. And there are many reasons why he
didn't publish his plays. Um first of
all, in this culture at this time,
there's no
copyright. So if you publish your play
and someone steals it, too bad. So
you're not incentivized to publish your
play. Second of all, people don't really
read and write. So there's really no
market for his plays. So even if he were
to publish his plays, he wouldn't make
any money. He he would make money. He
would not make money off it. Okay. So
what he did was he wrote his plays down
um primarily for his actors to
memorize. But as but but the but but the
benefit of America is that actually the
speeches are pretty easy to
memorize. Okay. And um when he was alive
Shakespeare was a national celebrity. He
performed his plays in front of the king
and queen. Okay. He was very very very
well known. Um extremely famous.
um he was looked down upon by the nobles
but I mean he was very very wealthy and
he himself will go on to purchase a
noble title for himself. Okay so he was
extremely successful
um when he was
alive people didn't really fully
understand his genius. Okay. It's only
about 100 years, 20 years afterwards
uh when people really appreciate his
genius and his play spread throughout
Europe especially to Germany to Germany.
The Germans love Shakespeare. Okay. And
it was only after his death that people
realized what a um unique genius
Shakespeare was. So
um after his death um his friends and I
don't remember their names, okay? But
his friends want to uh remember him.
They want to memorize him. Okay. So they
start to publish his plays. It's it's
something called the first folio. So
basically what they did was okay they
took um the notes from Shakespeare. So
some of surviving manuscripts not
complete okay but some of his notes.
They
also got the actors to basically write
down what uh they uh remembered. Okay.
And they remember a lot because these
are actors. Actors have extremely um
good memories. Okay. So they were able
to reme remember exactly uh the
speeches um and then they'll make
they'll make edits. Okay. And this is
the first portal first for folio. Okay.
But as you can imagine over time
there'll be a lot lots of additions and
mistakes. All right. But um so today it
there are thousands of Shakespeare
scholars and they argue over certain
words. Did Shakespeare really have this
word or was it a later edition? Okay.
And I
mean it's a really silly thing to do
because as I explained to you the genius
of Shakespeare was to imagine language
as this very fluid
um flexible imaginative tool for you to
experience reality onto itself. Okay. So
to argue what I mean like was the word
dagger or datter or dasher. Okay. And
people will argue this. I mean like does
it really matter? I mean like a lot of
Shakespeare is just word play, right? I
mean like there's really no deep truth
in Shakespeare and quite
honestly I mean like these words are not
are not going to change the deeper
meaning of Shakespeare. Okay. So so
something that I think overpaid English
professors do. Okay. Just because they
have nothing better to do. Okay. They
argue about what was the in the first
fortio what was edited out was added to.
They're trying to figure out what was
Shakespeare's original
intention. And I mean Shakespeare, think
of him as a musician, okay? He's I mean
like he's trying to um sing beauty and
truth, but a lot of it is not
intentional. A lot of it's not
conscious. A lot of being driven by
inspiration and intuition and
imagination.
Okay. Right. So when we go back to
Hamlet the silicquy if we change a few
words it doesn't really change the
meaning of the silicqu.
Okay.
Right. Okay. Does that make sense, Eva?
Okay. Great question though.
Right. Any other questions?
Yes. Yeah. So how's that like mindset?
Okay. Okay. So it's a great question.
Okay. Um what men's
burden? Okay. This is a concept that was
introduced during the age of imperialism
right at the end towards the end of the
19th century by Robert Kipling. Okay.
Okay, the white man's burden. We have a
responsibility as white people to go and
civilize the dark people. Okay, in
Africa and in China and other places.
Um, what's the connection to
Shakespeare? Okay, first of
all,
Shakespeare was not interested in the
world. Okay, he he was very provincial.
He was interested in London and that was
about it. I'm not even sure if he
traveled. Okay. Um, there's a debate
whether or not he actually speaks French
and Latin. He knows a bit of Latin, but
this is debate whether or not he speaks
French. Okay, so um Shakespeare was not
an imperialist. He was not a globalist.
He didn't really care about the world.
But within Shakespeare is British
culture. Okay, he wrote of
histories,
tragedies and
comedies. there's like 38 to 41 plays
and together they are the encapsulation
of British culture right so as Britain
was going out into the world and
conquering people uh and colonizing
nations they need to explain why this
this was happening okay why are you
going and killing people for like no
particular reason and this is why
Shakespeare is important because
Shakespeare
allows him to say, "Well, do you have a
Shakespeare? Do you have do you have
like 38 to 41 plays that are beautifully
written?" Well, if you don't, then that
means you're not
civilized. Okay? We have Shakespeare.
You don't have Shakespeare. That means
we're superior to you and therefore we
will teach you Shakespeare. We will
educate you in Shakespeare. We will
civilize you. Okay? So, this is not just
Shakespeare. There are other um um
individuals as well. Okay. But primarily
Shakespeare. Shakespeare is really the
um greatest cultural product of the
British.
Right. So that doesn't make sense. Echo.
Okay. So Shakespeare himself was not an
imperialist. He didn't really care about
that sort of thing. Okay. But his legacy
will be co-opted by British imperialists
in order to justify and explain why
they're going out and killing so many
people around the world and stealing the
resources. Right? Okay. But we'll
discuss this when we enter the age of
imperialism which is towards the 19th
century and and then this will lead us
into the great wars uh world war I and
World War II.
Okay. All right. Any more questions?
really
best way.
learn.
Yeah, I I I answered the question. Okay,
great. Great. Yeah. So, so you're you're
doing a fellow in class and you're
looking at a fellow from the perspective
of race and identity and culture,
right? Um okay. So, let's just discuss
how Shakespeare wrote his plays. Okay.
So, he wrote
um for around 40 plays before he died at
at 52. Okay. which meant that he was
basically
producing one, two, three plays a year.
That's a lot, guys. If you read
Shakespeare, the themes are extremely
diverse. Okay? You have a fellow who is
a Moore who kills his wife Desimona,
okay? But you also
have Merchant of Venice, Julius Caesar.
Okay? So, there's a wide range of his
plays. And so, the question is, how did
he do it? Well, he was stealing it from
everyone. Okay, remember this is a um
market. There's a huge market for
theater. There are dozens and dozens of
really talented playrs in London, in
England who are producing wonderful
works. Okay. So, he's just stealing
these plots from different uh
playwrights. But what makes Shakespeare
unique and special and superior to these
other playwrites is first of all his
characters. Okay.
um he has a deep
empathy
for his characters. He goes into the
mind of his characters and he says if
I'm this person, how would I behave?
Okay, so that's one thing that makes him
unique. Second, as we discussed, is his
use of language. Okay, just the
fluidity and the beauty. Okay, and the
flexibility of his
language. Okay. Um,
and the last thing is the realism, which
is he's trying
to make the plot as realistic as
possible. He's trying to remove the
supernatural elements. Okay, he's much
he's interested in psychology.
Okay. So, um, when you look at a fellow,
he's he's he's asking himself, why is it
that a man who loves his wife, what
could drive him to kill his wife? Okay,
that's the question he's asking. He
doesn't see Oll as a black person in a
foreign culture. He doesn't see it that
way. He just sees I want to ask myself a
question. If you truly love a person,
what would what would drive him to kill
her?
Okay. But because the theme is so
universal, it allows you
to impose
um cultural
readings. Okay. So he himself was not
interested in the issue of race, culture
and identity. And quite honestly at this
time in history there's no such thing as
race or identity. Okay? Remember I keep
on saying this but for most of you of
human ministry we did not differentiate
ourselves according to race. We
differentiate ourselves according to
community. Okay. So within England
people didn't care about the French or
the Germans. They hate but but you know
what they cared about each other and
they hated each other. Remember the main
conflict in England at this point is the
conflict between the Catholics and the
Protestants. Okay? So they weren't
focused on the world. They were focused
on each
other. So um these cultural readings
come later. They come from today.
Shakespeare himself was only interested
in psychology. What drives us humans?
All right? And you can see that
manifests itself in Oll and in
Hamlet. All right? And quite honestly,
um I'll be honest with you, I think it's
really unfair to Shakespeare that we're
doing
this. All right? I mean, like like like
like isn't it much it wouldn't be much
more interesting class if we stop asking
ourselves, oh, Oll was a black person,
so how black people were persecuted and
ask ourselves, Oll is a man of great
achievement. He's a man of great
tremendous pride and honor. But is it
possible that in in certain in certain
circumstances this can be used against
him and that's and that's the plot of a
fellow which makes it a Greek tragedy
right the Greeks were concerned about
hubris
arrogance fate these are questions that
the Greeks were concerned about so in
many ways Shakespeare saw himself as
continuing the Greek
legacy all right and the fact that we're
focusing on questions like race culture
and identity it sort of like degrades
the
because it's saying like, oh, if you're
a black person, uh, then you may always
be manipulated and persecuted. And quite
honestly, it's also reinforcing certain
racial stereotypes about black people as
very violent and emotional. Okay. So, if
I were to teach Oll, it's a great play
and I've never taugh, but I would focus
more on the human aspect of a fellow as
opposed to the racial aspect of a
fellow.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great. Any more questions?
That's a great question. How is
Shakespeare able to focus on human
psychology um given the fact that he's
not well educated? Okay, I will make the
argument it is precisely because he's
not well educated that he focused on
human psychology. Okay, when you are
educated, you are educated into cultural
attitudes, norms and values of the
elite. But if you're not educated then
what you do is you observe humans as
they are without prejudice. You want to
know you want to know how are we as
humans and you have not been
indoctrinated to believe believe certain
certain
things. Okay. So if you go to school you
do one school and you go to university
the first thing you're taught is only
well educated people are capable of deep
psychological insights. And that's a
prejudice. That's a failing because
Shakespeare never went to school. He's
able to see himself as equal to other
people and therefore he's able to have
tremendous empathy for other people and
therefore he's able to understand the
psychology and his own psychology. All
right? He's able to see people as a
reflection of his own psychology and
that's what drives his genius and that
and quite honestly that's what also what
what drove Homer. Okay.
So, um I mean um I I hate to say this,
okay, but I did go to Yale University. I
studied English literature there. So, I
stud I spent a year studying
Shakespeare. And
um I was not impressed with the
education I got at at Yale because again
the problem with going to these elite
universities is you're taught to think
in a very rigid
way that inhibits your
empathy, your
curiosity and your own psychological
understanding. Okay. In fact, I'll be
honest with you. Um, I watch a lot of
YouTube videos and like to do research
for these talks. I'm always impressed by
how these self-taught historians know
much more about history um than these
academics at Yale, Cambridge, Oxford,
Harvard. Okay, that I mean that's that's
something that that I I've observed. I'm
you're much better off talking to an
individual who has a passion for history
and who spent his entire life asking
himself what is history but never really
got a formal education never got a
doctorate in history as opposed to a
Harvard PhD in history. Okay, that's
that that's that's a hard lesson I
learned in my life. It was very hard for
me for me to accept because I am um an
elite um graduate of of elite
university. Okay. But what Shakespeare
understood intuitively is no, it's the
common
people, the ordinary people. That's
where the truth lies. Okay? Not in
books, but in people. That's that's what
makes Shakespeare so great. He's he is
first and foremost an anthropologist, a
psychologist of people. He wants to
understand how people think and behave.
Okay? And when you read when you read
his plays, that's what that that's what
you experience for yourself. Okay? He's
really interested in the psychology of
IGO Desimona and Oll.
Okay, that's a that that's what he's
that's what he's curious about. He's not
interested in these structural forces
that drive conflict and persecution
uh among these people. Okay, that comes
later. That that that's what we do to
Shakespeare today. Okay, but back then
he was only he was only interested in
what it meant to be a human being.
Okay. Okay. Does that make sense?
Okay. Great. Any more questions,
guys? You want to ask more about Oll,
I'd be happy to
answer even though my reading of Oll
might be different from what what you're
being taught in class.
Okay.
Okay. So the question is how does
Shakespeare develop his themes? Okay. So
um so
Oll
sorry so Athell Hamlet King Leair all
these plays are well-known stories okay
they're extremely well well-known
stories but Shakespeare he is curious
about people all right because every day
if you work in a theater you you deal
with people all the time okay your
customers are people your actors are
people and what he discovered over time
is people are very complicated. People
are very emotional. People have um their
own psychology. There's diversity among
people. Okay? And so what he does that's
really interesting is he takes these
legends and he combines them together.
Okay? He takes these legends and he and
he takes his observations of human
individuals and he combines them
together to create Shakespeare.
In other words, what he does that's
unique is he takes these characters,
King Lear, Hammond, he turns them into
people he's
observed. All right? When you do that,
you get you get a lot of interesting
psychology, right? So let's imagine um
you become Hamlet and you were in a
circumstance where your father has come
and told and given you a mission to go
kill your uncle because he's sleeping
with you know your your your mother and
um how would you behave? Well, you
probably like Hamlet and you'd be like
very confused. You'd be very distraught.
Okay, does that make sense? Same thing
with where
um let's just say that you're this great
champion. you're this great hero. Well,
other people are be jealous of you,
right? And if other people are going to
are are going to be jealous of you, what
what they're going to do is figure out
how to
um get back at you. Okay? So, it's not a
racial issue, it's a human
issue. If you're the top student in the
school and every day the teachers are
praising you, right, I'm pretty sure
those students are going to hate your
guts. That's a
fellow, right? That's a human thing.
It's not a racial thing. It's not
because he's black. I mean, it's because
he's such a uh accomplished
individual. Okay. Does that make sense?
All right. Great. Okay. So, um next
class we do the American Revolution. All
right.